and even as every other lck team Falls
away Baker stays standing 10 years ago
Faker won his first world seven years
ago he won his third and most recent
title one year ago he lost a very close
world's final and four months ago he had
to step down from T1 temporarily due to
an injured arm he returned to save his
floundering team they qualify for worlds
and this weekend they face jdg in the
semifinals we've been here before but
the question Remains the Same can Faker
actually go all the
[Music]
way all right before we jump in I want
to say thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring this video here's Liz to tell
you more managing my top tier and
extremely real East Sports organization
Elizabeth Sports is not easy I have to
make sure my players are well taken care
of of and to make that happen I've
decided to start my own business except
as someone in charge of an Esports or I
don't exactly have time to learn how to
code or commit forbidden black magic
rituals or however it is that websites
are made but thankfully this is where
Shopify comes in it's an all-in-one
Commerce platform that makes it super
easy for anyone to jump in and start
making money regardless of their Tech or
business experience level they even give
you access to Shopify learn a free
online course to develop the skills I
need to start grow and manage my online
business Shopify Powers millions of
businesses across 175 countries
including the merch for your favorite
orgs and us so if you'd like to see how
it can help you get your business off
the ground go to shopify.com thecore
Esports and start your free trial links
in the description below and now let's
get back to the video all right so it's
not been an easy year for fakers so far
in fact it may have been one of his
toughest professional Years yet last
year ended with a heartbreak breaking
five game series Lost to DRX a team
which had their own anime protagonist in
De and Faker left wondering what he and
his young Squad could have possibly done
better after a record-breaking year for
them then on July 5th this year during
the lck summer season T1 announced Faker
will be taking a temporary break after
pain appeared in his right arm and hand
replacement mid Lan of poby stepped in
and did his best but Faker shoes are big
ones to fill in his absence T1 last
seven out of their next eight matches
they looked a shadow of their usual
selves without their Talisman is now
carrier taking so much damage he will be
taken out Poe as well is going to
explode and somehow it's another kill
for the vain as well as owner is running
away PD finds the flash incinerate look
at how fast he's going it's a double
kill what aiming on four kills on Bane
at 6 minutes make it a triple oh
goodness me it could not have gone worse
for T1 when Faker returned the though
things changed immediately T1 won their
last two games of the regular season and
then battled their way through playoffs
all the way to the final where they were
taken down by a surging gen G second
place is well not first place you know
but honestly T1 would have absolutely
bitten your hand off a month earlier for
that result when they couldn't stop
losing and Faker still had a busted hand
it's honestly hard to understate just
how impressive this was Faker rallied
his teammates and writed the T1 ship
through his exper experience leadership
and very presence every year people are
expecting him to finally fall off and
this year he found even higher levels
when his team needed him most and need
don't remind you this guy has been like
the oldest player in the lck for about 2
years now at least I'll say the
platitudes for the end the result of T's
playoff run was them earning the lck's
second seed out worlds but by no means
were they favorites to win before the
tournament there was a strong argument
for jdg geneng even l or Billy Billy
being more likely to lift the Summoner
Cup this year the Swiss stage went
pretty much as expected with T1 only
dropping a game to their Kryptonite
geneng and advancing to the
quarterfinals with a 3-1 record going
into their first knockout game versus
lmg I'd say the odds were slightly in
T's favor but nobody expected T1 to
smash them we just spent the last few
days watching Chinese teams eliminate
the remaining lck representatives in KT
and geneng G there was somewhat of a
trend beginning to form but T1 didn't
just go toe-to-toe with LG they battered
them T1 stay standing the last Light of
the lck bird bright and buan as they
head to the
semifinals and now T1 finds themselves
in semifinals faker's sixth semis ever
which is mad most top players won't even
get to attend the tournament that many
times standing in the way of Faker sixth
final ever is is jdg and let's be honest
here they're terrifying the LPL
Champions are on track for something
that's never been achieved in League of
Legends history The Golden Road it's
League's version of a grand slam when a
team wins both their spring and summer
domestic titles MSI and Worlds the last
time we even saw a team come close to
doing this was G2 back in 2019 before
they lost in the world's final that year
now jdg have their shots they've gone
from strength to strength this year year
spring showed that the additions of
Knight in the mid lane and former world
champion ruler as the ad carry had
turned an already deadly team into
serious contenders after winning spring
they absolutely flexed at MSI not losing
a single series on their way to the
title including a close fourth round
Victory versus T1 and that's important
to remember T1 might have recovered well
over the summer the fakers well buff
might be in full effect but the last
time they played jdg they lost and that
will be in the back of their their minds
and since then jdg have won another
domestic title and now have their eyes
locked firmly on the Summoner cup for
them T1 is just another obstacle on
their seemingly Relentless March to the
final jdg are the bookie favorites here
and when you look at it logically it's
kind of hard to argue with that they
have only lost five Series this year but
with Faker you can't really think
logically the normal rules don't tend to
apply to him anime rules tend to fit
better faker's results sometimes feel
that they have less to do with what
would make sense and more to do with
what would make an incredible story he's
been writing such a story this year he
started it by having to recover from an
incredibly close world's finals that
happened just two months before in
summer he bust his hand and had to watch
his team absolutely death spiral without
him he then likely rejoined his team for
playoffs sooner than would be medically
advised and now against many people's
best guesses he and T1 are now one
series away from backto back world's
finals appearances Faker doesn't follow
logic he writes stories looking at
people's pickems a lot of fans seem to
have faith in T1 with over 75% backing
them to beat jdg and look despite what I
just said a lot of this isn't simply
wishful thinking T1 have rapidly
improved over the last few months and
especially during this tournament
they've developed into a clinical
versatile and disciplined unit that's
backed up by solid drafting in a meta
that suits them on the other hand this
iteration of jdg are experts at
nullifying their opponents in lane and
then smothering them in the mid game
simply by being some of the strongest
team fighters of this era this feels
like a final but of course it's not if
Faker and friends do manage to take down
jdg they'll still have to face either
Billy Billy or wayo in the final and
maybe we'll do a video about that too
because Faker would be about to fight
for his fourth world title ever 7 years
after his last 10 years after his first
but one step at a time anyone watching
who's a fan of like English football um
who knows the chat that
goes um we came up with a chant for
Faker at MSI based around that I feel
bad now cuz you know I like Faker and
that that was like a mean English
football champ